so
who would like to start
mr barnes why does sam aggravate you
15 seconds to drop so what's our plan
great
superheroes cannot be allowed
to exist
[Music]
i have no intention to leave my work
[Music]
unfinished
the wall's upside down right now
where do we start
i have a plan oh yeah what is
it is you ready here we go again huh
we've been grinding hard on the job
hello girl kick your ass
[Music]
see that wasn't so hard are you ready
is you ready ready okay what are you
doing
ready are you having a staring contest
are you ready
just blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and we just got a new
trailer for the falcon and the winter
soldier if he only caught what was shown
at the super bowl marvel did release a
full trailer which i just showed and it
has a ton of new information but
mostly it revealed that zemo is indeed
still
a villain we were wondering if he's
going to be good or bad because we know
he's going to be working with
sam and bucky but it does appear that he
is still a villain the reason they may
be working together is because they
might have a common enemy
an enemy of my enemy is my friend and
that could be why zema would be an ally
to them at some point in time the
trailer is awesome it's action-packed
and a lot of new footage is shown which
i will break down tomorrow
one thing interesting is that we did get
a picture of the old captain america
chris evans tomorrow i'll break down the
whole trailer and talk about all the
little tiny easter eggs in this trailer
in the meantime let me know what you
thought about it and let me know if you
spotted any easter eggs yourself
if you love marvel don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all of the latest
mcu content for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter don't
forget to like the video
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof